he's also hosting Allen Iverson the
answer one hour's sit-down interview
with Allen Iverson coming up Monday
night at 8:00 Eastern on NBA TV for
those who never saw Iverson or played
against him how would you describe his
game Steve I think competitor relentless
Dan a guy that played left his body out
there and then I think a guy that you
looked at and said it six feet 165
pounds how is he doing this
and he did it every second that he
played the game and and obviously a guy
that off the court you get a chance to
have all the conversations about who was
Allen Iverson and why but at the end of
the day he stays strong on who he was we
wanted to be and that's why he's Allen
Iverson I think one of those guys are
you always intrigued to get to know more
and more and more body culturally he may
have changed the game as much as anybody
I totally agree with you Dan and I asked
one question I said you're a cultural
icon and waiting for his response it was
Allen Iverson response he said I am no
dancing around it Dan and that's the one
thing you love about a guy when you're
interviewing that here if you could talk
to him for five hours there was every
answer was going to be totally the truth
and I think that's sometimes um maybe
got him into hot water when he was
playing at the height of his career but
that's the one thing I think people
around him play with him played against
him loved about him
the crossover the double crossover
against Jordan did you talk about that
with Allen Iverson we didn't get a
chance to talk about it but high for me
but it's in the piece and it's it's in
everybody's mind as obviously for me Dan
that was kind of like here's the
coming-out party for Allen Iverson
because of the play like you said the
double crossover Howell can't cross you
wants Michael got you out of position
all in the same play I'm gonna do it
again and then the recover from Jordan
just as look like he wanted to block
that shot there so bad
couldn't and Iverson knocks down they
said they lose the game but I think that
was a coming-out party that play I know
as Jordan ever talked about that when
Iverson crosses him over I don't know
that's a great question I would love to
if somebody had okay Steve if you were
with Jordan and you had a chance to sit
down and talk to him would you wake up
that play to him I think so I mean
obviously that's the one play if I'm
talking to George about AI I think for
sure I mean and also for a guy like
Jordan who are used to him being on the
other side you know we were talking
about the plays he made and I think for
him is what did you think of a guy a
sixty scoring machine like you you know
me whereas we know that position for at
six feet was a traditional point guard
that could score but not a guy who had
the mentality and I was gonna score
every trip down the Steve Smith NBA on
Team TNT joining us from Oakland after a
Game one why are the Stephon LeBron
embracing this as a rivalry I don't
think that is so much of those two as a
rivalry I think to rematch I think it
will get very interesting um whether who
wins this series if they can get back I
think because they don't play each other
far as I did those two garden each other
I think that's one reason and I don't
think us in the media we bring it up
more and more we're not making it to the
storyline we touched on it and then we
go away from it
yeah but Bird and Magic didn't guard
each other they didn't play each other
that often no but you know those two
guys had that look while they wanted to
destroy each other and what's so special
about those guys they were they were
friends not friends on a court they
respected each other and I think because
of the history they had leaned up from
college and made it more of a rivalry
yeah I'd love to see them embrace that a
little more but it feels like you know
they're trying to make it this a they
team rivalry more than an individual
rivalry but it it feels like LeBron
wants to show the world who's the most
valuable player now he won't necessarily
say that but I get the feeling that he
wants to say hey Steph was Player of the
Year
I'm Most Valuable Player I think that I
think he wants to show that it's time
for me to once
keep getting to these championships who
has been phenomenal sixth Street that is
time for me to start winning something I
mean is obviously to have that that that
record to be able to achieve there and
get to the promised land but when you're
two and four I think next for him is he
wants to have a chance to start to get
some more double use versus is being two
and five yeah but you like oh I think I
brought this up yesterday would you
rather be to a no in the NBA Finals or
two and four I would rather be two and
four but if I'm gonna get there as a
competitor there I rather be six and oh
I mean you want to get there win what I
mean other than I would think last year
even for him you know he had to probably
look back and say wow you know my guys
were hurt but if everything is equal and
you had that chance which they do this
year because everything is equal I think
he wants to win I think you want to get
there every year and I think you want to
win it every year
if we had a draft right now but with
Golden State and Cleveland who's first
pick who's the first pick between out of
those two I think for sure
I still take LeBron James as of right
now okay so if I take LeBron and then
you take LeBron I get Steph your next
pick is probably I would say klay
Thompson okay then it's up to me I'm
probably going to take draymond Green
right you agree with that
I would agree with that yes so three of
the top four players in the NBA Finals
play for Golden State
um as where we starting to starting our
team right now yes I would say fire
starting our team yeah and then you're
taking Kevin Love or Kyrie Irving I'm
taking Kyrie Irving because the LeBron
James can do so many things that's why
LeBron kind of feels my point guard you
know my power for my small fort and then
I have you know klay Thompson shooting
the basketball Steve Kerr breaking the
clipboard last night do you think that
that do you think his team responded
when they saw him I think
embarrass debug the clipboard clipboard
you know I love Steve I play with Steve
a colleague of violet Turner that
clipboard I said somebody must have had
that as a property didn't hit is that
hard but I guess as we got a chance to
talk about it
pelleve done that before but I I think
like you said he surprised himself I
mean that's the perfect break he hit it
right where you needed to great for TV
but I'm live why I want to see Steve do
that again we think that it might have
been sort of broken so when he hit it it
was going to shatter and then his his
players would go oh my gosh Steve is
upset on us I loved it I was trying to
see that he had the pan to depend headed
or his fist hit it you know when oh the
marker you had in his hand but it was
fantastic to get a chance to watch his
reaction and I love Luke Waltons
reaction day he didn't blink
look like here we go again
alright everybody seems to give us their
favorite Michael Jordan story what's
yours well I think for me you know it's
so many I mean for me to get a chance to
go up against Mike I know just playing
against him um just a chatter we had
it's so many to go around I'm trying to
think of one
is there a cutthroat one is there one
it's like oh my god now he finger wagged
in your face team yeah dikembe I mean
we've had some but I think all the
Mike's just kind of cutthroat they might
have a smile but they all had a
cutthroat off then he tell you at the
foul line ER so like he I would say the
one thing my rookie I always go back to
Dan you know I got when that he had
played 36 holes of golf and I said
there's no way he doesn't mean whether
it was true maybe somebody added
eighteen more but to play golf before a
playoff game weathers the day before or
that you know that you get a chance to
come out and I think we were going back
chattering chattering I think he had
three points after the first quarter he
end up with 53
I still can't believe he played golf at
got it came up with 53 in the playoff
game that my rookie year that's the one
that still has me baffled and I really
wanted to know it was totally true
whether it was 18 or 36 old would you
rather it was 36 and he got 53 on you or
it was only 18 and he got 53 onion he
was just at the tribe what do you think
was tougher the big Ulf game that day or
playing you and getting 53 you know I've
been happy with the first round oh man
he was one of those guys that was
there's a lot of stories the love to
have a sit-down with Michael to go
through some of his basketball I guess
stories well congrats on the Iverson
sit-down that's coming up the one hour
sit-down with Allen Iverson Monday night
at 8:00 Eastern on NBA TV Steve thanks
for joining us thank you they appreciate
it the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience